mr. president how are you sir an honor
to see you
wave to the fake news video
hello folks it's great to see you how
are you to see you understand what do
you wanna dance and what is your camera
timing right here first you can thank
Laura Ingram was given us extra Hannity
time tonight well she's very special and
she's doing well you know what she's
doing well she's a big supporters are
yours
what do you make of where the Cavanaugh
hearings are now there's a new set of
demands that have come out I think it's
a very sad situation he's an outstanding
person and frankly Shawn to see what's
going on is just very very sad you say
why didn't somebody call the FBI 36
years ago I mean you could also say when
did this all happen what's going on to
take a man like this and be spurts now
with that being said let her have her
say and let's see how it all works out
but I don't think you can delay it any
longer they've delayed it a week already
and you've been very out you've been
very accommodating have been
accommodating I said let her say what
she has to say and let's see how it all
comes out but they've delayed it a week
and they have to get on with it
mr. president you you're dealing with a
lot a lot of good economic news today
and there's a lot of media people seems
like all they ever talk about and John
Solomon and Sarah Carter broke a big
story tonight great people and what
they're saying is is that even the
intelligence community in the FBI didn't
want to give the Intel to the Obama
administration because there were
conflicts and they would weaponize it
against you that's our new information
well I'm not surprised to hear it if you
look at what's been going on over the
last couple of years and I'm not just
talking about from the time I won the
presidency this took place when I was
winning
in the primaries I mean you look at
what's going on I'm not surprised to
hear anything before the election after
the election even the media leaked
strategy lisa page had testified that
for nine months they had no evidence at
all whatsoever but it seems to be coming
to an end
well it has to come to an end it's so
bad for our country I call it the witch
hunt it is so bad for our country and
when you see Strock and page and mccabe
with his lies they gets fired for lying
you see all of the things and Comey for
lying and leaking you see what went on
it's got to come to an end
so bad for our country the irony in all
of this is I have been uncovering all of
this when you think about it
Clinton bought and paid for use funneled
money a dossier foreign national put it
together la yani
they never verify hope they never
corroborated and it was the bulk of
information you have now you have now
said he classified and we're Deckard how
soon will that be coming well moving
along we're working along we're also
dealing with foreign countries that do
have a problem I must tell you I got
called today from two very good allies
saying please can we talk so it's not as
simple as all that and we do have to
respect their wishes but it'll all come
out you know what elections are about
peace and prosperity your economic
record I talked about it earlier in the
show tonight record low unemployment 14
states african-americans Hispanic
Americans women youth unemployment we
have great news on the economy better
news with Kim jong-un he's not firing
rockets over in Japan well with honestly
Korea North Korea South Korea things are
working out very nicely tough sanctions
against Russia and the Iranian economy
and the Chinese economy are both going
down as you have taken a tough stand
well it's time to take a stand on China
we have no choice you know it's been a
long time they've been hurting us and
our farmers are great and our farmers
are starting to do very well again it's
very interesting but we're putting very
very heavy sanctions and other things on
various countries and we're getting
along with some countries but we've been
ripped off Sean by the world all of
these countries for years and years that
we can't do it anymore so getting better
deals with Mexico and a good deal with
Mexico good for both good for Mexico
good for us everybody's happy NAFTA was
a disaster we lost thousands of plants
we lost millions of jobs NAFTA was a
disaster we've renegotiated it
we're in the process of working now on
Canada we'll see what happens with
Canada Canada's been tough they charge
300 percent tariffs when dairy products
our farmers no good you can't do that so
we'll probably be able to we'll see what
happens I know that's why I'm one count
well anyway go ahead I'll last one last
question is there's a lot of people in
this arena waiting for you as you can
see
I'll ask one final question amazing
47 days from now is the midterm
elections 47 days we know what the
agenda the Democrats are they want to go
after you they want endless
investigations they want to keep
Obamacare they want to eliminate ice
they want open borders they want the
crumbs back your tax cuts and I question
is the question that every American
ought to ask is are we better off than
we were two years ago what do you say to
those people that love you but maybe are
so hot on their Republican House or
Senate member you got to go out and vote
we need more Republicans we'll get
everything we want we need more
Republicans you want to protect your
Second Amendment you want to protect
everything you want to protect all of
the great success that you've had over
the last a little more than now than a
year and a half think of it we're coming
up can you believe it on two years when
you and I started talking actually this
is what happened you came down the
escalator well yeah if you talk about
the campaign itself but I will say this
you've got to protect look at what's
going on with the Supreme Court if we're
not there because we're all together as
a group if we're not there to protect it
is going to be some really bad day for
this country so we're protecting but we
made tremendous gains you know the stock
market today it's a good day to do an
interview because the stock market today
hit the highest level in its history
today
now did you work this interview out no
civically for that but it was up very
big today but it hit the highest all of
the markets today hit the highest level
now 401ks are up 57 percent in a short
period of time if the Democrats get in
those numbers will be cut in half you
will see amazing Obama never made the
only president in history that never
made 3% GDP growth in a year all right
the budget negotiations are you going to
demand you challenge Republicans fund
the wall completely will you insist on
getting 1.6 billion will continually we
spent 3.2 billion we're continuing to
build the wall I'd like to do it I could
do it so quickly I'd like to do it in
one piece the Democrats are holding us
back
I am told by Republican leadership and I
hope they do it because there are a lot
of people counting see the people with
the wall I want the wall to
they got it down that they will do it
immediately after the election we've got
a billion six a lot of money but not
when it comes to got three billion you
spent we've got 3.2 billion it's being
built we've got a billion six but we
have to do much better than that because
we could do it very quickly and you know
the bottom line we need it the Democrats
they want open borders they want people
coming and that means crime with the
opposite you gotta have a border you
don't have a border you don't have a
country you know security secur secur in
our it's about and you want a door in
your wall well it's going to have lots
of doors people are going to come in but
they're going to come in through merit
and they have to come in because we have
companies moving in from all over the
world they're coming back to the United
States the biggest companies Foxconn the
biggest companies in the world are
coming back we need people but they have
to come in through merit mr. president
thank you thank you can you think Laura
again she's probably gonna be mad at me
Laura I love your show I watch it all
the time and you know what you are
special you really are it's a good
combination Thank You mr. president
I know these crowd would be ready to
hear the president thank you sir we
appreciate you thank you so much